the sandis administration directs
Florida universities to terminate
student chapters that sort support Hamas
terrorism now the first thing I thought
when I saw this was this is this is a
misplay this is Ron going too far in the
culture War targeting free speech from
students I don't I don't like that they
support this stuff but we want these
far- leftists to go out and talk about
how they support Hamas and then you
actually read it Ronda sanus is correct
in this regard these individuals are not
just speaking the let me read this the
States the student group present at at
least two universities in Florida known
as the national students for justice in
Palestine published a toolkit that
refers to the Hamas operation as the
resistance and says that Palestinian
students in Exile are part of this
movement not in solidarity with the
movement quite literally I believe
that's a violation of federal law in
providing material support to terrorist
organizations so in this capacity it
goes well beyond just speech and it's
difficult I always try to be careful and
and and and I would I would uh
personally require a lot of evidence and
and adjudication on this I don't want a
government a governor or president to be
able to come out and be like nope you
said you support terrorists so we're
shutting you down like no no no no we'll
bring it to bring it to court you
shouldn't be able to just just do this
they should have they should have filed
something that they should have to
respond to there should be a uh due
process here the letter explains that
it's a felony under Florida law to
knowingly provide material support to a
designated foreign terrorist
organization these chapters exist under
the leadership of the national students
for justice in Palestine who distributed
a toolkit identifying themselves as part
of the operation Al AXA flood based on
the national s spj uh SP JPS sorry
support of terrorism in consultation
with Governor DeSantis the Student
Chapter must be deactivated these two
student chapters may form another
organization that complies the Florida
state statutes and University policies
the two institutions should Grant these
two chapters a waiver for the fall
deadlines should reapplication take
place now my question here is if they
genuinely believe these individuals are
supporting terrorism why would they be
like just refile wouldn't they be like
we are going to arrest and charge you
for this well what people always forget
now especially is that Hamas is a
designated foreign terrorist
organization that has been the case for
decades in Republican and Democratic um
uh Administration so that's leg one of
this whole statute about you know I used
to prosecute guys for providing material
support to terrorism it can be arms it
could be money it could be planning it
could be whatever right conspiring with
them to do bad stuff
so you have that piece of the puzzle are
they a designated foreign terrorist
organization but here's the thing that's
not Florida law it's federal law right
so anything in Florida that speaks of
that is is superseded by federal law on
material support statutes so you're
right this is I agree that if they're
providing money to a foreign terrorist
organization it's it's material support
what if they what if they claim to be
and are providing labor well then you
have to go to court and prove that
you're providing labor that is not
attributed to terrorist activity right
you're I'm saving babies in you know
wherever and providing food to the
homeless or something like that so we
get into this we get into this problem
when we have all these humanitarian
refugee camps right like across Syria
and all of these donors want to give
money and you're like well we're giving
it to all these people and known foreign
terrorists who are in the camps that run
the camp how are we going to Pro what
are we going to do with that that's been
an ongoing issue for a long time what do
you think of Tom Cotton he had that he
wrote that letter to meorc saying we
need to expel foreign Nationals who
violate federal law by espousing support
for Hamas because you're not you're
you're barred from it's it's the law
like you know this doj won't actually do
it because it's it's the doj along with
the state department has to get together
to make that you know ejection possible
but what he's saying I think you have to
break it down a little further than just
expel everyone if you are affiliated
with a known foreign terrorist
organization Hamas in America and you
are supporting them in the very least
you should be kicked out of the country
and more likely prosecuted what normally
happens you get prosecuted then you get
stripped to your citizenship or
residency status then you get the boot
do you think any of this is likely to
happen though that's what I find to be
the crazy thing there's going to be all
of this Fury and the progressives
themselves are divided over the issue
but nothing will happen from the Biden
Administration not in this one and stuff
like this is going to become more common
in the internet age as these people are
able to coordinate more freely ium well
like look so the difference between
Al-Qaeda and Isis I mean the main
difference right Al-Qaeda they brought
yourself and your team to wherever Stan
mountain region they were to train you
up kit you out and send you back out to
do your thing Isis just did it online
that was their deal that was their that
was their whole recruitment platform you
don't need to come to you know
Afghanistan or Pakistan we're click here
and donate click here and learn how to
fire an AK-47 and then eventually maybe
you'll come down range and go to one of
our camps so that's already happening
and our problem has been you know it's a
free speech thing what if these guys are
in these chat groups or in these you
know Pro Isis organization chapters and
they're saying well I just support what
they say I don't support what they do
it's it's it's hard to prosecute that
it's hard to make that call and it's
hard for I think for a lot of like the
Free Speech Americans who do believe in
that like especially because a lot of
them were younger right a lot of those
Isis those kids who got involved with I
was like in Minneapolis or whatever like
those were they were like barely out of
their teens a lot of the one of the
arguments I hear all the time is that uh
especially with the like first
generation Americans whose are you know
of one culture and you're kind of torn
between the two they look for identity
online and become radicalized and so
that's a very difficult and sad story to
pedal on the other hand you know
ultimately if the conclusion is
radicalization you have to treat that
really
seriously yeah it's not fun I waited
through a lot of those cases it's but
you know people always forget you're
like we focus on designated foreign
terrorist organizations right because
that's the federal law material hook for
material support and it's not like we're
just going after the KKK right like
obviously I hate those guys but most of
what they say is protected Free Speech
their right to even organize and convene
together is protected on their
constitution that's the way it should be
right but there's a separation between
what the KKK does and what Isis and
Al-Qaeda and Hamas and all these other
organ Hezbollah all these organizations
do you know you're talking about people
who have done so much destruction to
American and American Allies that the US
government was like you're you're on the
list for Life yeah um
that's it there's like almost no getting
off of it yeah I wonder what you think
of uh the organizations that are saying
you know they won't hire these students
from Harvard I think lar Hogan just did
that because some people say you
shouldn't cancel them you shouldn't talk
like there is an argument that that's
not fair on the other hand like if
you're hiring someone and they advocate
for you know terrorist organizations
that we have recognized since like what
1997 that's pretty serious well first of
all all these all these institutions are
private they can do whatever the hell
they want they could hire whoever they
want they can come out and say we don't
want Harvard guys who had done xw y or Z
they could have done that is it
different when Larry Hogan says he won't
hire from Harvard well if he's saying
that if well he's not Governor anymore
so I don't know where he's hiring these
people but if he's hiring them for
government jobs somewhere then that
that's going to be an issue but if if
even if like say JP Morgan right the
world's largest bank is like yeah we're
not taking anybody from Harvard because
of this nonsense okay what are they
going to do it's totally within their
right to say that yeah we're going to
hire murderers do you think it will
change how
Academia those guys are too that's what
I always think that they're sort of lost
institutions so yeah but a lot of these
students started writing letters being
like no no no no no we're so sorry we
didn't know and then you got people
coming up being like these students
really didn't know it was in the letter
we should uh be nice to them a lot of
these students are Marching uh they they
they've not changed their mind these
students go to Harvard they're not
stupid they well they are Harvard that
would be right that would be their KN
jerky you know argument I went to League
school I'm a brilliant is that a worst
indictment that like you go to Harvard
but you didn't
like that's that that might be it's like
I'm not hir I'm not not hiring you
because you said you support I'm not not
I'm not hiring you because didn't read
you didn't read the damn paper right
like how or you're lying that you did
read it and now you're trying to be like
oh no no I misunderstood either way all
of those are very bad yeah it's not
great it's just going to get worse I
think I think it's all connected like
those institutions like Harvard yeah
whatever any AV League school is
connected to this entire hypine movement
that we've been talking about when these
people flip when these people write
books when they go on TV when the person
who's the person that just went got
kicked out of somewhere and is now like
the uh professor at uh at Princeton or
or Yale this just happened this week uh
I'll think of it anyway you get rewarded
they're part of the reward system we're
going to be make you president of this
institute we're going to give you
contract what's funny about this there's
a voice actress named Tara Strong and uh
she's the voice of like Timmy Turner and
bgirl Harley Quinn so a lot of people
who are familiar with like DC Comics and
and cartoons have heard her voice she
was on Drawn Together on Comedy Central
she got fired from a show because she
was tweeting in support of Israel so the
show abruptly tweeted out that she would
no longer be voicing one of their
characters and then she starts losing it
like I'm being I'm finding out from the
internet I'm being fired for being
Jewish things like this but what I find
fascinating about many of these people
uh Tara has me blocked right because
she's one of these woke leftists and
despite the fact that we always calmly
and rationally tried to explain to them
that these the BLM and the farle want
the eradication of Israel they plug
their ears and say you're far right you
know blah blah blah and then the
Reckoning comes for them as as as we've
been warning about for so long these
people who think they can keep their
head down and just s the left will be
left alone that's not true she gets
fired because of this unless you have no
opinions whatsoever like literally you
would have to have no opinions
whatsoever cuz eventually no but then
they ask you you're staying quiet on
this issue you're staying quiet on this
issue why do you comment on that's what
happened to V ramaswami exactly they
kept demanding he keep speaking up and
he was like I did they're like more and
he's like I've had it this has been like
the number because we we've just been
talking a lot cuz everyone of the all
these celebrities have something to say
about what's going on right now like
you're not involved in this like you
don't need to have an opinion on this
stuffit it's all of their publicists
that have something to say who are
saying you really really need to tweet
about this thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net